[Music]
so
[Music]
good and evil were the specific
differences yielded by the thought of
spirit as immediately existent since
their antithesis has not yet been
resolved and they are conceived of as
the essence of thought each of them
having an independent existence of its
own man is a self-lacking any essential
being and is the synthetic round of
their existence and their conflict
but these universal powers just as much
belong to the self or the self is their
actuality
in accordance with this moment it
therefore comes to pass that
just as evil is nothing other than the
self-centeredness of the natural
existence of spirit
so conversely
good enters into actuality and appears
as an existent self-consciousness
that which in the pure thought of spirit
is in general merely hinted at as the
othering of the divine being here comes
nearer to its realization for picture
thinking
this realization consists for picture
thinking in the self-abasement of the
divine being who renounces his abstract
and non-actual nature
picture thinking takes the other aspect
evil to be a happening alien to the
divine being
to grasp it in the divine being itself
as the wrath of god this demands from
picture thinking struggling against its
limitations
its supreme and most strenuous effort an
effort which since it lacks the notion
remains fruitless
there is an awful lot going on here in
paragraph 777
quite a bit of it is continuation of
what's been happening in the earlier
paragraphs on the overall
development of this
section you notice that there's quite a
few references to picture thinking that
is foreshadowing and there's also
uh
one that you might not catch in part
because of the translation where it's a
verbal
form right talking about something being
conceived and the word there is for
stealth
so
all of this is at this point
taking place
in terms
of fortune picture thinking imagination
representation is another way that we
can talk about it
you notice as we get through
all of these i won't use the word
distinction since that's actually one of
the words that we're going to be talking
about here but all of these dialectical
progressions that are available to the
phenomenologist towards the end
of this paragraph we see it explicitly
turning to picture thinking
and it's
not getting it right we see that um
this demands from picture thinking
struggling against its limitations its
supreme and most strenuous effort an
effort which since it lacks the notion
remains fruitless what is the notion
well the concept because is another way
of talking about this and that's the way
that we need to
ultimately
understand make sense of
what religion is really after and what
we have here is picture thinking and
this is you know this is kind of an
achievement it's not to be
dismissed it's an important
step on the way right struggling against
its limitations picture thinking can
even be
aware to some extent not entirely of
course because that's the realm of the
concept but aware to some extent
with its of its limitations and then
struggle to go past them
the trouble is that when it does so
it either uses picture thinking you know
just sort of taking it to a higher level
or it uses what hegel will call
elsewhere the philosophy of the
understanding rather than the philosophy
of the concept
or it could uh degenerate to a lower
earlier kind of
shape of consciousness and it's a way of
accessing the world making sense of it
making sense of itself and thereby you
know go go further straight but here
hegel is as we've said so many times
before
he's charting out the success stories of
the dialectic not where the dialectic
ends because it it gets into an impasse
or because it finds a stable dynamic
that it's going to remain in
until something else comes along to
supplant it all right so let's go back
to the
start of this paragraph and
chart out what's going on so we've got
from the previous paragraphs good and
evil
right
and these he says
exist in an antithesis and i've remarked
uh previously that whenever we see that
word antithesis we do want to go back to
the german because miller has a has a
tendency to translate several different
things by antithesis well this is
antithesis in the strictest sense this
is contradiction gig and zots right
so it's not just mere opposition being
set you know in opposition to each other
and gagan because that's the right it's
not
merely distinction or something like
that this is
contradiction
and
well why wouldn't we have
absolute contradiction we're talking
about
things that are you know fundamentally
contradictory aren't we good and evil i
mean true and false it's hard to get
more contradictory
than that
and he tells us that these were the
specific differences yielded by the
thought of spirit
as immediately existed so
i want to hesitate on this this word um
uh differences right which could also be
translated
as distinctions which would be a little
bit closer to it uh onto right
so things that have been
separated things that have been
uh put apart there are differences
that's true but distinction is a little
bit closer to that and i think one of
the things that we need to
get so bishempton you know specified um
particularized you know specific works
here
these are distinctions of thought and
thought at this point is not mere
thought right even if it happens to be
abstract as we're going to see in just a
bit but you know thought is what we're
working in
and
these differences exist you could say
between good and evil
but
you know when you think about this good
and evil were the specific differences
yielded by the thought of spirit as
immediately existent
okay so
each of them
is not just different from the other or
distinct from the other each of them
is also you could say
a modality
of making a distinction or distinctions
the good doesn't distinguish things in
the same way
that the evil does they are different
ways of
distinguishing and
making sense of the world and of
themselves and of their opposite or you
know antithesis
in this case right
going on he says since their antithesis
has not yet been resolved which implies
what well it will be resolved eventually
just not here in this paragraph right so
since their antithesis has not been
resolved and they are conceived of as
the essence of thought that conceived of
as i was saying a little bit earlier
for gestalt right so they are being
better put
represented or imagined or pictured
as
um
at the essence of thought the and this
denkins right
each of them now here's an interesting
point
each of them having an independent
existence of its own
hegel doesn't use the word existence
here uh
in this this
portion of the paragraph he uses it
plenty in the rest of the paragraph so
having an independent existence of its
own
you can translate it that way it's a
yada physique subscribe
each of them is
independent
for itself or on its own account or
taken in its own
terms
and this is how they are being
represented
by the
the human person right well and by the
religion too
so
existence each has at least being on its
own each
is independent this is the way that
they're understood they're not really
independent of course but at this point
it kind of seems that way to the
human being and so because of this
because their antithesis not yet been
resolved
human being man mensch is a self lacking
any essential being
where is the essential being
on the part of good and evil
right
and so a self lacking any essential
being but
also
because where do good and evil
exist who do they exist for
uh human being
he the human being is the synthetic
syntheticia once again we see that term
coming up
and notice too that we have antithesis
we have uh synthetic we don't have
thesis antithesis synthesis going on
here right instead we have a more
sophisticated approach to antithesis or
contradiction if you really want to be
uh you know much more close to the the
idea and synthesis the human being is a
synthetic ground
putting together things
bringing them into connection with each
other things that are opposed to each
other the synthetic round the bowden
of
what
of their existence their design
now here we actually have dozen right i
remarked that um you know these things
don't actually have
uh
independent existence as such they are
they're independent
right um but now they are said to have a
dozen
but
where's that dozen grounded in human
being right the human being
is what gives them their their
independent being and their conflict
their kampf
and i think this is quite interesting
conf you know i said well you know
there's different terminology that hegel
uses that we sometimes translate as
antithesis
and um you know some are stronger than
the other kampf is a stronger term
than just gagen zots right kampf is
actual fighting against each other
gaganzatz is you know contradicting each
other so you could say we've escalated
from words to fists or you know to
some sort of violence against each other
but this is all
for the human self
unessential self right what's essential
are these thoughts
so he goes on and he says these
universal powers just as much belong to
the self what are the universal powers
good and evil um you know these are
mecta powers
forces you could say right these just as
much belong to the self or the self is
their actuality if they're going to have
any actuality any vehicle
it's going to be because
the self gives that to them
so then he goes on and he says
in accordance with this moment so we're
learning something here it therefore
comes to pass that just as evil
is nothing other
than the
self-centeredness
of the natural existence of spirit okay
let's pause there for a moment
the self-centeredness of natural
existence we've had plenty of uh
references to that plenty of discussion
of that particularly in the morality
section
uh in in spirit a lot earlier right the
natural existence the natural being of a
being often contradicts its moral
aspirations its
you know
acclaimed values or its status or
something like that in this case the
natural existence of spirit what is the
natural existence of spirit how spirit
is in human beings who
follow their natural inclinations and
desires to use a rather conscient
formulation
and the self-centeredness now you know
this is really quite
a good translation
uh even though it's not a literal
translation in zikayun was referenced in
earlier paragraphs as something that
consciousness is is doing or things are
doing right uh objects of consciousness
they have an indication which is
different than uh you know on zigzag
right gain is to go into
yourself to retreat to
hold yourself up you could say or to
explore
self-centeredness is not a very good
literal translation of that but
the way that hegel in general is going
to conceive of evil
and the way that many other people do as
well evil is what
winds up being
too self-centered not you know too
narrow of a self-identification
and its interests and pursuits
and valuing the self above everybody
else okay so that you know that kind of
works for
a concept of evil
a notion of evil giving it a name
so
because of this do we do we find out
what good is
no and we're told that good almost as a
response almost because evil exists like
this
good
enters into actuality
um
the actuality that we were just talking
about a moment ago enters into ein steps
into uh actuality
and then this is interesting and appears
as an existent
self-consciousness
so i mean evil is
a self-consciousness isn't it or the
evil self-consciousness who's selfish
too self-centered good
enters into actuality as an existent
self-consciousness a self-consciousness
let's read between the lines
that is
taking a stance that's different than
that of evil
maybe you know we could say looking to
the interests of more than one person
caring about the group thinking about
something bigger than itself identifying
the self with that as part of its
actuality as opposed to the evil which
says
screw the bigger picture i'm in it for
me right
and so he says good enters into this and
this is you know continuing this
antithesis so he says that which in the
pure thought of spirit is in general
merely hinted as
as the othering of the divine being
again discussed in the previous
paragraphs right
here comes nearer to its realization and
here hegel
doesn't uh use what word we might
normally expect
in terms of realization right like uh
you know uh veer click kite or vehicle
going or something like that or even
fulfillment right of
folendi kite
no it's really
the latin it's becoming real which
doesn't mean becoming real in the same
way as becoming
actual but becoming real for
something for
picture thinking he says this
realization consists for picture
thinking in he mentions two
uh actually three things here that are
connected with each other um the
self-abasement of the divine being right
the lowering literally of the divine
being who renounces his abstract and
non-actual
nature god becomes one of us god enters
into relation with us
um picture thinking takes the other
aspect evil
to be a happening alien to the divine
being so
you know if we want to take this very
explicitly we could talk about christ
right christ becomes incarnate the
second person of the trinity the son the
word becomes the man-god you know and
suffers dies you know
is tortured crucified all these things
those those are evil that's being done
to christ being done to god who has
lowered himself into
our plane
and yet this isn't all evil it's not
like well god okay god's like super good
then
and so wonderful and you know takes on
our sufferings and sins and knows that
well that's all true
but
we also have a third thing going on here
to grasp it to grasp what evil
in the divine being
as the wrath of god
this is also part of not just the
christian heritage but and not just the
jewish matrix that came that it comes
out of influence of course by
zoroastrianism
bringing in all sorts of other elements
it's not just found in other religions
where the gods can be
angry
or you know punish human beings this is
this is kind of a constant right and
this is a real problem for
a theology that has you know god is the
god of love god would never
be mean to anybody well what about the
wrath of god
i mean this pose such a
interesting
problem for early christians that
loctancias writes an entire treatise
about this
engaging with not just you know
religious concept but also the
philosophical literature of his time
about anger some very sophisticated
engagement of thinking with this issue
of the
wrath the era the anger
of god
so
um how do we how do we bring these
together well from the perspective of
picture thinking we can't we're stuck
oscillating between things and and it
sounds not only as if evil now is within
human beings it sounds as if evil could
even be within
the divine
right and so that is going to cause a
lot of problems so he says picture
thinking takes the
this other aspect to be happening just
to the divine being trying to grasp it
as the wrath of god this demands
from picture thinking it's supreme and
most strenuous effort but
that effort remains fruitless why
because picture thinking is a little bit
too
even though it's very sophisticated it's
still a little bit too rigid it's still
a little bit too given to taking
differences or distinctions as if they
are once and for all
and you know apply it's corresponding to
what i've called following hegel and his
lectures on the philosophy of religion
the philosophies of the understanding
not a philosophy
or religious comportment
of the notion or concept
the alienation of the divine being is
thus made explicit in its two-fold form
the self of spirit and its simple
thought are the two moments whose
absolute unity is spirit itself
its alienation consists in the moments
going apart from one another and in one
of them having an unequal value compared
with the other this disparity is
therefore twofold
and two relationships arise whose common
moments are just those given
in one of them the divine being counts
as essence while natural existence and
the self count as the unessential aspect
which is to be superseded
and the other on the contrary being for
self counts as the essential and the
simple divine being as unessential
their still empty middle term is
existence in general the bear community
of their two moments
paragraph 778 is following up now
talking about the divine being which was
being brought up at the
end of the previous paragraph talking
about how
through picture thinking or
representation for styling rather than
the concept we're not really able to
reconcile to to work through
the
not only contradiction but conflict comp
in the previous paragraph between two
sides and we see this continued on here
now talked about in terms of alienation
and
so the rich vocabulary of opposition
going on here but there's a there's an
interesting development that's taking
place as well which we could read a lot
into but perhaps we won't uh do quite so
much of
as we did in the previous paragraph so
he says the alienation of the divine
being the
what what's the alienation we're talking
about here the alienation due to trying
to understand
evil
in terms of the divine being evil is
something that happens to the divine
being become incarnate but also as
the wrath of
god
he's not going to talk about these terms
here but he says this alienation of the
divine being
is made explicit in its two-fold
form so we've got two things that are
opposed to each other the self of spirit
the serbs des geistes so this is going
to be kind of important to bring up this
terminology and then on the other side
we have
it's translated as
well enough it's simple thought right
gadonka is thought here
and einfacher uh it's zein what's the
zion referring to what's the it's
referring to the self of spirit so
you've got the self of spirit which is
not alienated in relation to something
totally different than itself
but it's it's alienated in relation to
its own simple thought and you can say
well this is part of what happens when
you have self-conscious subjects
self-conscious
selves
and he tells us
that
these are two moments whose absolute
unity
absolute
uh
you know
einfach heights right is
spirit itself and now notice the play on
words here right
geist zelpst
das alps des geists right spirit itself
the self of spirit is all in this unity
but that alienation is there
it's not just a illusion to be you know
overcome so we can
grasp spirit itself in an
undifferentiated unity or something like
that no no we want the concept
and that's yet to come so
he tells us that this alienation
consists in
and here we get another doubling you
could say
the moments going apart from each other
ao sign under titan now
this is something we should think about
how do they
literally
step outside of each other
um how do they take a step into it right
outside of each other well there's this
uh process that's happening within the
self is spirit right and thereby within
spirit
itself where this the the
geist zelpst is differentiated into
these two that can be
alienated from each other and they step
apart from
each other they go apart from each other
thereby
becoming something that can be
not only grasped by consciousness but
ways in which consciousness is grasping
even more important one of them having
unequal value
compared with the other value is virt
right a value in the very broad sense
and
both of them
can have unequal value compared to the
other as we find out because as hegel is
going to go on
in this
section
he says
this disparity this when glycite
unequalness right and glycite is a
reference to
having unequal value unequal vieta
in comparison to each other they are
perhaps incommensurable or
each of them represents themselves as
being greater or lesser
than the other they mistake their
their genuine relatedness value and they
set themselves up as independent from
each other
in this way so part of the going apart
from each other is is like
conceptualizing actually not
conceptually representing
these unequal values right so the
disparity
is here the translation is is twofold
literally is the twofold right is
the
doubled the
uh thing that is being double this this
disparity so the
unequalness the
the not lining up with each other is
itself what is doubled in this process
so we not only have doubling here we
only have a double process here this
disparity itself is going to be doubled
and he's and he goes on to say two
relationships arise
whose common elements are those just
given common moments right what are the
common moments of spirit it's simple
thought
and one of them in one of these
relationships the divine being counts as
essence while natural existence and the
self count as the unessential aspect
which is to be
superseded so the divine being is what
really matters
natural existence the self unessential
have to be canceled have to be
hoping to have to be raised up have to
be
transformed in some way so that's one
way in which these can
relate to each other and the
other way is what
being for self counts as the essential
and the simple divine being
as unessential
which one corresponds to which
well i mean i think it's pretty tempting
to read this as
its simple thought
is the abstract
con grasp of of the divine being
so
in that case
um divine being counts as essence
natural existence in the self count as
the unessential the self of spirit would
be the natural existence of it brought
up in the previous paragraph and then
being for self would be essential the
simple divine being unessential
and now notice remember in the last
paragraph we had a contradiction that
was unresolved right
unreconciled on work through why because
we're dealing with representation not
yet the concept
and hegel gives us here a
still empty middle
term
existence in general
the bare community of their two
moments right so
it's not the same thing as the
alienation it's not i mean it could be
the absolute unity but the absolute
unity is conceived of as kind of just
meh blah right just what it is
we're not getting there yet but we're
now
on our way
you